Okay, let's start class.
So,
um let us summarize and review where we
are so far in the story.
So, um there are three major interest
forces that are pushing the United
States towards war with Iran.
Um the first is the
Israel lobby.
Remember that the Israel lobby is
composed of both Jewish interest as well
as Christian interest, right? Uh
representing uh the Jewish
interest is something called AIPAC.
Uh and they have a membership of about
800,000.
But
they're very wealthy. There are many
billionaires in this group. So, this
group has financial power.
In fact AIPAC is considered the second
most powerful lobbying organization in
the United States. The first is
um the pensioners, okay? There's about
30 million of them.
Um and their lobbying organization is
the most powerful, but AIPAC is second.
But also in the Israel lobby are the
Christian Zionists, right? So, for
example, the organization uh Christians
United for Israel has 7 million people
um in its membership.
So, together the Christian Zionists and
AIPAC um are extremely powerful force
in government, and they want a war in
the Middle East in order to advance
Israel's interests.
Also remember that
America
is now addicted to empire.
Because empire represents easy money.
All money
has to be uh channeled through the US.
And so, there are many people in the US
who just make basically make their money
by speculating on money, okay? So, for
for example, Wall Street. And that has
made Wall Street extremely powerful uh
right now in US politics.
And the third um force
is Saudi Arabia.
Um remember that in our discussion of
Saudi Arabia,
we learned that
the major conflict in the Middle East is
actually not between Israel and Iran,
but between Saudi Arabia
and Iran.
For Israel, Iran is a security threat
because it it supports Hezbollah and
Hamas.
But for Saudi Arabia,
um Iran represents a threat to its very
existence.
Okay? So, Saudi Arabia must resolve the
Iran
problem
soon.
Right? Now,
how these three forces manifest
themselves is uh through Trump, okay?
So, basically Trump is their champion.
And
privately,
um there's a man named Jared Kushner,
who is Trump's son-in-law. He's married
to um Trump's very daughter,
um
Ivanka Trump, okay?
And Char- Jared Kushner
happens to be very good friends with
both Benjamin Netanyahu,
who is the leader of Israel,
as well as Mohammed bin Salman, who is
the leader of Saudi Arabia.
Now, uh Jared Kushner's father, Charles
Kushner, was a very prominent
uh sponsor of AIPAC.
In fact, when Benjamin Netanyahu comes
to stay in the United States, he lives
with the Kushner family.
So one night Benjamin Netanyahu had to
stay in Jared Kushner's bedroom and
Jared Kushner had to sleep in the in the
basement. Okay, that's how close they
are.
And Jared Kushner is friendly with MBS,
the leader of Saudi Arabia. So for any
that when Jared Kushner started a
private equity fund
Saudi Arabia invested $2 billion.
Okay, so for Jared Kushner
these three forces are able to exert
influence on Trump.
As we also discussed it's very likely
that Trump will become president of the
United States again
in November and he will pick Nikki Haley
as his
VP.
And that means that Nikki Haley will be
the one in the Trump White House pushing
for war against
Iran. As we discussed Nikki Haley makes
most of her money from the
Israel lobby, okay? The anti-Iran lobby.
We know from the first Trump
administration that these forces are
able to exert tremendous influence on
Trump, okay? And the evidence is one,
Trump withdrew from the Iran nuclear
deal
that would have secured peace between
United States and Iran.
Okay, Trump moved the United States
Embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
in Israel
which
was a major
which caused major friction in the
Middle East, okay?
We also know that
Trump ignored the fact that MBS killed
a journalist.
Okay, so we also know that Trump
has been very friendly with Saudi
Arabia. We also know
that
Trump sponsored the Abraham Accords,
which is trying to bring peace between
Israel and other Arab countries
and unite them against Iran, okay? The
last thing that Trump did, which is the
most important, is that in January 2020,
Trump ordered the assassination
of General Qassem Soleimani, who who is
the leader of the Revolutionary
Sorry, who was the leader of the Iranian
Revolutionary Guards.
Okay? So, from all this, we can suspect
that a second in a second Trump term,
uh war with Iran will be a major
priority.
Right? So, is this clear so far? All
right. Now,
we also discussed that, okay, even
though there are there are these forces
that want war with Iran,
ultimately, it is the US military that
must implement this war.
And if the US military refuses to go to
war,
then the war can't happen.
So, we discussed that
unfortunately, the US military is very
different from what it was 30 years ago,
okay? 30 years ago,
the US military maintained very standard
military doctrine, okay? They maintained
three very important principles that all
militaries must maintain in a time of
war. The first is
mass forces.
Uh B is um avoid encirclement, right?
And the third is protect supply lines.
Now, the the important idea is that when
you fight a war like this, okay, which
is traditional warfare, you must have
the consent of the public.
Okay? Because it is the public that
sends soldiers, that provides money,
that gives you political support.
But,
in 2003,
the US military changed its military
doctrine to one of shock and awe.
Okay? And what shock and awe means is
that you don't have to follow these
three principles anymore. You can use
air supremacy.
Um you you also have technological
omniscients.
And you also have special forces.
And this allows you to fight wars
cheaply, quickly, and decisively, so
that you no longer need public local
support for fighting wars. And as we
also discussed, this created the idea of
hubris
in the American military. So, the
American military, because of the 2003
uh war in Iraq, are confident that they
can win any war, any place, against any
enemy.
We know that this doctrine
is actually not true. And we know
because of something called Operation
Prosperity Guardian.
Okay? So, um a few months ago,
the Houthis, which are a rebel group in
in Yemen, they started to attack ships
in the Red Sea. Okay?
Um and a lot of trade goes through the
Red Sea. So, the American military
dispatched a massive naval force against
the Houthis.
Were the Americans able to defeat the
Houthis?
No. They were not.
And so, what the what are what are what
are the Americans going to do about it?
What can they do about the Houthis?
What's the What's the solution to this
problem? You have these pirates, the
Houthis, going around and attacking
these uh ships, which is affecting
um international commerce, and that's
why inflation is such a huge problem
right now
in the world.
So, what are the What's American
military going to do about this?
What can they do about this?
The answer is nothing.
Okay?
The American military has no solution.
Why? Because they don't have
the forces necessary in order to
undertake an operation against the
Houthis. They have special forces, they
have air supremacy, they have
technological omniscience satellites,
but they don't have infantry. They don't
have lots and lots of ships.
Therefore, they cannot stop the Houthis.
Okay?
And what's Winning Point is that Joe
Biden has come out and said that, "Yes,
we know we are losing the war in the Red
Sea,
and yes, we know that we cannot stop the
Houthis, but we are going to continue
on this path."
Okay? Does that make sense? This is the
idea of hubris.
Not knowing your limitations. And when
when you are faced with your
limitations, you refuse to accept your
limitations.
Okay? And that's why when the US
military is given the order to invade
Iran, they'll probably go along with it
because they cannot imagine the
possibility that they could be defeated
in Iraq.
Okay?
And then,
you have
the
Iran
Revolutionary
uh Corps. Okay?
The Revolutionary Guard.
And as we discussed last class, they
want war with the United States
because
um they're very angry about US
interference in Iraq, right? So during
the Shah regime, which was a brutal
police state from 1953 and then 1979,
the Americans were the ones who were
backing this police state.
So there are many who are who are angry
about this.
They're also
um angry about the fact that the US
continues to protect protect Israel and
Saudi Arabia.
Okay? They're also angry about the fact
that Trump killed General General
Soleimani, okay?
Um and as we discussed, it's possible
that uh the Revolutionary Guard Corps
killed last week the president of Iran,
uh I- Ibrahim Raisi, and all because
um
he was preventing war.
Okay?
So
they want war with the United States. So
you see the map, right? You You see the
logic of this.
Where there are powerful forces in the
United States pushing the United States
towards war. You have Trump who has
basically agreed
in his first term to raise or increase
escalation with Iran.
Within the Trump White House, there will
be Jared Kushner and Nikki Haley to push
this war both privately and publicly.
The US military
um has so much hubris that they think
they can win this war, and Iran wants to
provoke the United States into into
invading it.
Okay? The United States and Iran can
have many and for so Iran has many many
um strategies in order to provoke the
United States into war.
Okay? Basically, the United States is
looking for a reason, and Iran wants to
give them a reason. And that's why I
think war between the United States and
Iran is very likely in the next 2 to 4
years.
Okay, any questions so far? Are Are
clear about where we are so far? Be be
before I I move on.
Any questions?
Okay.
So, now let's talk about the actual war.
So,
here most of this is speculation, okay?
But, um I'm using speculation in order
to help us
better understand what a war would look
like.
Okay?
So, let's pretend that it's March
2027,
okay? And Trump goes on TV.
He announces Operation Iranian Freedom.
A full-scale
US invasion of Iran. Along with Israel,
Saudi Arabia as its main partners,
but the United the United Kingdom, UK,
will be involved. Australia will be
involved. UAE will be involved. Poland
will be involved.
Okay? So, you have many countries
attacking
um
Iran together.
And Trump goes on TV and explains to
American public why the United States is
fighting this war. Okay? And this is
what Trump says.
First, he says that for the past year
there have been violent protests in
Iran.
You have religious protests. You have
political protests. You have ethnic
protests. The Iranian people are sick
of the Ayatollah. They are sick of the
dictatorship. They want democracy. They
want freedom. In response, the
Revolutionary Guard are killing
thousands of protesters.
Iran is on the brink of civil war.
Therefore, the United States has an
obligation to protect
the people of Iran.
Okay? The people of Iran are praying for
of and democracy, and the United States,
the world's greatest democracy, must
give them
democracy. Okay? So, the first reason is
freedom and democracy.
Second,
US intelligence, along with Israeli
intelligence, have discovered that for
the past 2 years,
Iran has been working very, very
hard on developing a nuclear bomb.
In fact, Iran is only 1 month away from
having three nuclear
bombs.
So, that New York City,
San Francisco, and Los Angeles and Los
Angeles could all be destroyed.
Okay?
So, to prevent this, we must strike
first to stop Iran's nuclear program.
Okay?
Third,
Iranian proxies, the Houthis, Hezbollah,
many groups, have been disrupting
shipping
in the Middle East, in both the Red Sea
and the Strait of Hormuz.
40% of the world's oil passes through
that region, mainly to East Asia, China,
Japan, South Korea.
Our global prosperity is at stake.
We must go to war to protect these
shipping lanes and ensure that the oil
goes to China, Japan, and South Korea,
so that they can continue their economic
prosperity. So, the United States, as
the world hegemon, has a responsibility
to protect global prosperity.
Okay?
Fourth,
Iran has been launching attacks against
our allies, Saudi Arabia and Israel.
Hezbollah
has been violently attacking Israel,
killing dozens of Israelis, innocent
Israelis.
The Houthis have been attacking Saudi
Arabia oil fields, damaging the economy.
We have an obligation to protect our
allies, our friends in the Middle East,
okay?
And the last reason is
we know for a fact that the Iranian
Revolutionary Guard Corps is a sponsor
of terrorism.
Last week in a mall
there were gunmen who went and killed
170 people.
Our intelligence says that it was most
definitely an Iranian operation.
Okay? So, for these five reasons
we have decided to
invade Iran.
But, don't worry.
This invasion will be successful
because we have a lot of allies.
The UK,
Israel, Saudi Arabia, all friends will
be part of this operation.
Our special forces are already in the
country
looking for their airbases and their
missiles.
We can knock them out at the beginning
of the war.
Also, we have been in in contact with
Iranian opposition groups.
They want to overthrow the regime. And
when we help them, they will install
democracy in the country.
Our American military is the greatest in
the world.
In 1991, our military defeated Saddam
Hussein in 100 100 hours.
In 2003, our military defeated Saddam
Hussein in only in less than 3 weeks.
To prove that
we are the greatest in the world,
we will defeat Iran in only 2 weeks.
So, do not worry.
We will be strong
in protecting democracy, freedom, and
global prosperity.
Okay?
So, that's what That's what Donald Trump
will say to the people of the United
States, okay?
And of course, you're going to have
large-scale protests throughout the
country opposing this war.
But, most people
in the country will support this war.
Okay?
All right.
So, after the speech, the operation is
launched.
And
on TV, we'll watch this on TV and the
internet together on YouTube together,
okay? And we'll be so impressed
by the power of the US military.
Um this is Iran.
This is the Strait of Hormuz.
Saudi Arabia
um
Israel is here.
Red Sea is here.
Iraq is here. Okay?
So, in the Strait of Hormuz comes the
USS
Gerald R. Ford. It's a $13 billion
supercarrier.
Okay?
This thing is designed to destroy
countries. It is now pro-prowling
the Strait of Hormuz to ensure that
shipping is safe.
America establishes air supremacy very
quickly, okay? Meaning that it has
complete control over the skies.
Nothing can move in the skies without
America
detection.
Okay?
And
then a massive
invasion force is sent to Iran in the
south.
100,000
US troops land. Maybe 200,000 Saudi
Arabia troops land, okay?
Maybe you have
300,000 to half a million troops in
Iraq.
And they are about to strike Tehran
in the north, okay? So in the south, the
United States and its allies have
established a foothold.
They have a huge presence in the country
and they're about to attack Tehran,
okay?
All right.
You understand what what what what has
happened?
Okay.
Now I'm going to ask you this question.
At this point, I think the war has been
decided.
Who has won the war?
America has has established air
supremacy. It controls the skies.
US Navy controls the seas. You have
100,000 US troops in country ready to
strike Tehran.
The war has been decided. Who has won
the war?
Okay. Obviously, this is a trick
question. Obviously, Iran has won the
war. Why?
Why?
What's the problem with this plan, okay?
This is typical American doctrine, shock
and awe. This is how they fight wars.
But there's a problem with this plan.
What is it?
Why would the Iranians want this?
Maybe
like when they're occupying the south,
no one wants
Okay, let's go back to
traditional
military doctrine, okay? In traditional
military doctrine, you have three
principles, right? Mass forces, avoid
encirclement, protect supply lines,
okay? These are the three three things
you must absolutely
obey if you want to win the war, okay?
So, using traditional military doctrine,
explain to me why United States has lost
the war right now.
Exactly. First of all, they're
encircled, okay? Do you know why?
Because Iran are all mountains.
It's a fortress.
Okay? Meaning that to get
these troops into the country, you have
to air drop them.
Right?
But guys,
once you're in the country, you can't
get them out of the country. You
understand?
Okay, so that's the first problem.
They've been encircled.
Right? What's the second problem?
They can't actually
go
north. Why not? Like it's too heavily
defended because of all the mountains.
That's right. And what else? And like
it's very hard to
move like tanks and equipment through
mountains.
Yeah, that's
that's right, okay?
So, they failed to mass forces, okay?
Iran is a population of 90 million
people. You will need at least three to
four million soldiers to even think
about conquering the country. They've
got 100,000 in this country, okay? And
as Jack says, you can't move tanks
through mountains.
They're not designed for mountain
warfare.
What are they going to do?
Okay?
So, they can't mass forces,
and they can't and they've been
encircled, and and what else is a
problem?
And this is the biggest problem.
Exactly. They cannot be resupplied,
okay? They have no supply lines.
For them to be resupplied, airplanes
have to drop ammunition, food into the
country. But again, Iran is all
mountains. So, it's very easy
for Iranians to shoot down the
airplanes. Does that make sense? When
you pass through mountains, you can't
see what's on the ground. A guy, a
random guy with a rocket launcher, can
just shoot down the helicopter, okay?
Which is what the what the Afghans did
against the Soviets in the Afghanistan
war.
And that's why they the Soviets lost the
A drone can take down any airplanes,
okay?
So, in other words,
these guys are trapped.
They you think they're soldiers, but
they're not. What they really are
hostages.
Okay?
Does that make sense?
You have too many people in the country,
so you can't get them out of the
country, but you don't have enough
people to actually launch a strike
against Tehran.
You can't resupply them.
And they've been encircled by Iranian
forces.
All right? Does that make sense?
Okay?
Okay.
Now,
the logic of having 100,000
US troops in the country
is that once you're in the country, all
the resistance to the regime will rise
up
and strike against Tehran.
The Iranian army will muti- will mutiny
against the country. Okay? That's the
hope.
Why do we think this won't happen?
Why won't the Iranians revolt against
their government?
Why don't they want to revolt?
That's right. Okay, so Iranians hate
Americans, okay? Remember that Iranians
remember the Shah.
From 1953 and until 1979, the Shah, the
American-supported Shah, was running a a
brutal police state. So brutal that
everyone in Iran revolted against the
regime, okay? That's number one. What
What Why else would the Iranians not
support the Americans?
Why?
That's the first reason.
Iran has a bad history with America.
Why else?
Guys, which country is next door?
What happened in Iraq?
America destroyed Iraq, right? From 2003
until 2011, America was there destroying
the country.
America said that it would bring freedom
freedom democracy.
It would bring prosperity. It would
bring wealth. But instead, it just
destroyed the country. American soldiers
were running into houses every night,
pointing guns at children, destroying
homes,
and arresting men for no reason, okay?
Iranians saw all this
on TV.
They heard about all this from
neighbors,
okay? So they know that if America
comes, it's to destroy the country, not
to bring freedom democracy, not to bring
prosperity, it's to destroy the country.
That's why they're going to fight.
Okay?
Um and another reason is that
Iranians
think that they belong to a great
civilization. So they value their
freedom and independence, okay? Does
that make sense? They're not going to
submit to a foreign conqueror.
So
um
why else would
the Iranians resist?
Okay.
Also, religion, right?
The Iranians are religious.
They believe that
um key
that say America is Satan, and they have
a duty, a religious obligation, to fight
Satan, okay? So, for many reasons,
there's just no way that Iranian people
are going to stand with America. You
might have a minority, but most are
going to are going to resist.
Okay?
Okay, so does that make sense?
Okay, any questions so far?
And why
do the Americans think that they will
rise up then?
Okay, so
uh that's a great question.
Why would the Americans think that the
Iranian people will rise up? And the
answer is that they need to justify the
invasion.
Does that make sense?
They they have to have a logical
explanation for why this invasion will
succeed.
Because one of the criticisms against
them will be like,
"You need 4 million people to invade
Iran. You don't have 4 million soldiers.
They have at most 1 million soldiers,
okay? Total throughout the world."
Um they have about 60,000 in the Middle
East. So, they can't get a million
soldiers.
So, the only explanation is, "Okay,
well, we're going to pretend that once
we invade, the people of Iran will
support us."
Do you understand?
So, it's not based on truth, but but
it's it's a explanation for why the the
invasion will succeed.
Does that make sense?
Yeah, but the doubt was like, what they
tell the public, but do they actually
believe
Oh, you know, that's a great question,
okay? So, that's their propaganda, but
do they actually believe this? And the
answer is um
hubris, okay?
They do believe this, because they have
hubris. And and again, um
it's hard because we're not in the
position.
But once you're in that position where
you have access to nuclear weapons,
when you can kill anyone in the world,
when you can see everything in the
world, um it makes you think you're God.
Okay? And we we we Remember like last
semester we were reading the Greeks. And
the Greeks believe the worst thing is
hubris.
Because it makes you think you're God,
but you're not God. And you you're going
to get into a lot of trouble if you
think you're God, okay? Okay. Does that
make sense?
Okay. All right. Any more questions?
Okay. So,
um
Trump says that Iran is 1 month from
developing a nuclear bomb, right?
America's been saying this for the past
10 years.
Okay? You just You just Google this. And
America's like, "Oh, Iran is only 1
month away from a nuclear bomb." They've
been saying this for the past 10 years.
So, do you understand? When Trump gives
a speech, there's actually no evidence
that any of this is true, okay? But this
is how he he'll explain the invasion.
Okay?
All right.
And chances are that even if Iran
uh possessed a nuclear bomb, they won't
use it. Why not?
That gives America a reason to use its
bomb.
That's right. Um the the reality is that
there's only one way that America can
win this war against Iran, okay? They
can just nuke the country. And America
will do that if if it has enough if if
it has a pretext.
Okay?
So,
nuclear weapons is something that Iran
is very afraid of.
Okay? So,
does it make sense? All right.
So,
this becomes So, American soldiers are
trapped in this country.
Okay?
So, now the question then is
Wait a minute here.
Why would America do something so stupid
as send 100,000 soldiers into the
country for no reason and get them
trapped?
Okay? So, that's a question.
And what I want to do now is make you
the argument that
um there are two ways that we can
prove or provide evidence that this is
true, okay? The first is historical
analysis.
Historical analysis means that are there
historical examples like this?
Okay? Are there historical analogs? If
there are, then this could be true,
okay?
The second uh method is through game
theory analysis.
Why would the actors who are rational do
something as stupid as
trap 100,000 American soldiers in Iraq?
All right? So, we'll first do historical
analysis
to find historical analogs, examples
that are similar similar to this.
And then we'll look at game theory
to to try to reason out the motivation
of the actors.
Okay? So,
let's first look at
game theory. Oh, sorry sorry. Let's
first look at historical analysis, okay?
So,
the year is 415
BC, okay? In Athens.
We remember that we studied Thucydides,
the Peloponnesian War, last semester,
okay? So, so so we're we will now
discuss the Peloponnesian War.
The war is for The year is 415 BCE, and
for the past
um 17 years, Athens have been fighting a
brutal war against Sparta, okay? It's a
stalemate.
And then for whatever reason,
um a man named
Alcibiades Alcibiades, okay?
has a suggestion. Okay, and this
suggestion is to win the war against
Sparta, let's go invade Sicily.
And
uh Nicias,
his opponent,
is like, "Why the hell would we want to
invade Sicily? It's far away."
And Alcibiades is like, "Well, because
it has a lot of money. If we invade the
country, we can take their money."
Okay?
And it turned out, by making this
argument, the people of Athens really
support this argument, okay? They
Because the When the reason why is war
was costing them a lot of money.
And they become addicted to the easy
money of empire, okay? So, they want to
fight this war.
So, Nicias
has this great idea of how to convince
people not to go to war.
Okay? And what he says to the people is,
"Okay, guys,
I know you want to fight this war. I
know I know you want to I know that you
think this war is a good idea, but
Sicily is a huge place. It has a navy.
Therefore, we need a massive expedition
force against
Syracuse in Sicily, okay? We need at
least 5,000 soldiers. That's a lot,
okay? Because their total Athenian
population is about 50,000 people, okay?
5,000 soldiers is a lot is a lot for
Athens.
And we need about 100 ships.
And the idea is Nicias is trying to
scare people
into
not agreeing to not fight, okay? That's
the idea.
The Athenians say,
"That's a great idea.
Let's send a massive force against
Sicily and Syracuse, so the war can be
can be won just like that, okay? Shock
and awe."
So, they So the problem though is that
never before in his history has Athens
sent a large expedition force against
another power. Okay, does that make
sense? When the Persians that invaded,
they were invading Athens. Athens didn't
go and invade Persia.
So when you have sent a massive
expedition force against another
country, what is your number one
problem?
What is the thing that you must resolve?
But the Athenians didn't really think
about it because they had actually no
experience
in fighting a foreign war.
Okay. Uh so yeah, so
the other the enemy knows the terrain
better than you do, okay? But there's
actually a much bigger problem than
that.
And it is what?
Okay, the biggest problem is resupply.
And this is something that the Athenians
didn't think about because they never
thought They they they never fought a
war
like this before, okay? So they sent
this huge expedition against Sicily. And
Syracuse,
um which was a naval power, were
surprised because they were like, "Why
would the Athenians want to invade us?"
Okay? So for the first year, the
Athenians were destroying
uh the Syracuse army. And the Syracuse
army had to retreat back into their
city, okay?
And so the Athenians laid siege to the
city. Okay, the Athenians Syracuse is
here, the Athenians are here.
And the Athenians control the sea,
right?
Okay? So this situation is very similar
to this situation, okay? Do you
understand?
But then what happened was that the
Athenians
couldn't resupply themselves. And the
reason why is Syracuse had also had a
navy, and they could stop the Athenian
navy from resupplying the Athenian
troops. And therefore,
the Athenian army was wiped out
in
Sicily. And this caused the Athenians to
ultimately lose the war against Sparta
and it caused the Athenian empire to
collapse.
Okay? Do you understand?
And
again, historians have been trying to
figure out for a long time why the
Athenians would do such a stupid thing
as send
as send such a huge army against
Syracuse. Because the risk of failure
was catastrophic.
Okay? And the only answer is, well, the
Athenians
had hubris, okay? They never really lost
a war
and they had become addicted to empire.
Which is the same situation America
finds itself in today.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
All right?
So, this has happened before in history.
When the Athenians invaded Sicily and
lost to Syracuse. Their entire army was
wiped out in Syracuse.
Okay? Because they couldn't resupply
their army.
Does that make sense?
All right.
The second example
we can look at is the Vietnam War.
So, in
in the beginning of 1960, okay? The
beginning of the decade, most Americans
have never heard of a country called
Vietnam.
Okay? Most Americans didn't know what it
was, they didn't know where it was,
okay?
By the end of the decade, in 1969,
half a million
American soldiers were in the country.
Destroying everything, okay? But also
getting destroyed themselves. 58,000
US soldiers died in Vietnam.
So, the question then is
how this happened? Why would this
happen?
1960, Vietnam was a distant country no
one has ever heard of.
By By the end of the decade, half a
million US soldiers were in country
fighting this war against an enemy they
really didn't know, okay?
In 1971,
um
the Pentagon Papers came out.
The Pentagon Papers
uh was a history of America's
involvement in the Vietnam War dating
back to 1950s, okay?
And it made three major points. The
first point is that
American leadership, military leadership
has been expanding the war in Vietnam
without public knowledge, okay? This is
what we call mission creep.
So, maybe at first they sent some
observers to the country, then they sent
some advisers and trainers, then
soldiers, okay? So, mission creep.
Slowly over time,
um things escalate. And you don't really
understand why things escalate, but they
do, okay?
Second point is that American leadership
from very early on knew the war was
unwinnable.
This was the greatest military in the
world. They dropped more bombs in
Vietnam in the '60s
than all bombs were dropped in World War
II, okay?
And they could not win the war. The
reason why is
to win a war, you have to solve three
problems, okay?
Okay, the first problem is
clear strategy, okay?
What are you trying to accomplish
in this country?
What are your clear
military objectives, okay?
Second is
you must adapt to the
battlefield. Okay? Because all your best
plans will change over the course of the
battle, okay? So, the the the adversary
that is most willing to adapt
to the battlefield will win, okay?
The third thing is
the will to fight.
So, if you want to look at a war and
who's most likely to win the war, you
ask these three questions. One, does
this guy have clear military objectives
that everyone understands?
Because that will determine strategy,
okay?
Second is
is this guy adapting to the battlefield?
The third is is this guy
um does does this guy still have the
will to fight?
If If the answer is yes all three
questions, then the person will most
likely win the war.
Okay? And if you look at the Vietnam
War, even though
America was killing a lot of people, it
killed 3 million Vietnamese during the
course of the war,
it was not destroying the enemy's will
to fight. In fact, it was making them
angrier.
And therefore, more people people
willing to fight the Americans.
Okay? So, from a very So, very early on,
the American political leadership knew
the war could not be won.
So, then the question then is
why did America stay in the war? And the
answer is credibility.
Okay?
Credibility just means they didn't want
to lose face. They didn't want to be
laughed at by the Chinese and by the
Soviets and by the Europeans, okay?
But, there's actually another uh way to
understand credibility. And it's it's
what I call the
sunk
cost
fallacy.
Okay?
Have you guys heard of a sunk cost
fallacy?
And the idea is
never ever go into a casino.
The reason why is that
when you go to casino
you start losing money.
At some point you cannot leave the
casino. Why not?
You feel like you've lost so much so now
you have to make it back. Exactly. You
want to You want to reclaim the money
you've lost, okay? You've invested so
much that you cannot leave. You have to
get that money back. And that's the
problem with war. Eventually, you've
invested so much you cannot leave the
war. And that's what happened in
Vietnam. America invested so much it
can't It didn't want to leave the war
because it did not want to admit that
all this
um has been lost.
Okay? It's what we call the sunk cost
fallacy. And that's why
even though America could not win the
war, it still want to fight the war.
Okay? Does that make sense? Okay? So,
the Vietnam war
is another example
okay, that is similar to to this.
Where America invest
enough soldiers
that it refuses to leave the war and
admit defeat, okay?
Does that make sense, guys? All right.
Now, let's look at one more example. And
this is the most recent example and it's
the Russian-Ukraine war.
Now, as you know, in February 2022,
Putin ordered
a special military operation against
Ukraine.
Okay? And uh this is Ukraine.
And Russia attacked from three axes,
okay? The north
to take Kiev, the capital. You have the
east to take Donetsk.
And then you have the south from Crimea
from
uh
Crimea to take the south, okay? And as
we know, uh the north
failed, okay? The north attack failed
and the Russian had to turn back. But
the east
and the south was successful, okay? Now,
let's think about this.
You have an extremely powerful military
attacking your country, the Ukraine.
If you were the Ukrainian president, if
you were the Ukrainian military, there's
really only one way you can fight this
war and win.
And what is it?
Using traditional military doctrine.
What how much you fight this war?
You guys know?
Let's go back to mass forces, avoiding
circle men, protect supply lines. How
much you fight this war?
There's only one way you you you can
fight this war.
To me?
How do you destroy supply lines?
There's only one way you can fight this
war and win. And what is it?
The The enemy's attacking you, right?
So, what what must you do?
Okay. The answer is you must retreat.
Okay?
Why?
The enemy's attacking, right? So, you
pull back your forces.
Why would you do that?
What's the logic of that?
Because then they have longer supply
lines. Exactly, okay? It's it's that
simple, okay? You want to overextend
your enemy. Ukraine is a huge country,
right? And and Russia didn't send send
that that that many soldiers. Maybe
160,000. That's not that many soldiers.
So, if you just give them a space,
they're going to outrun the supply
lines, okay?
And then when they outrun their supply
lines, you can encircle them and you can
disrupt their supply.
And that's the only way you can win the
war, okay?
What did the Ukrainians do instead?
That's the only way to win this war, but
what did they what did the Ukrainians do
instead which made them lose the war?
Yeah. So, the Ukrainians refused to give
up give up space, okay? They refused to
give up land. They want to fight the
Russians
for every inch of territory.
And eventually, because the Russians had
more forces, mass forces, they were able
to push push through, okay? So, that's
the first major mistake that Ukraine
made.
But then, last summer,
Ukraine launched something called a
counteroffensive, right? So, once Russia
was able to take space, it did it
because and because Russia is a land
army, it started to develop to develop
um fortifications, defenses, okay?
Mainly artillery. And that's three lines
of defenses. And in the summer
offensive,
the Ukrainian military, for whatever
reason, sent tens of thousands, hundreds
of thousands of soldiers against their
this artillery, and the Russians they
blew every everyone up, okay?
Now, here's a question.
Why
are the Ukrainians doing this?
They've lost the war now, right? They
have no more soldiers. Right now, the
average age of the Ukrainian army is
about it's over 40 years old. They have
guys in their 60s and 70s fighting
in the military. They don't have enough
manpower. The war is lost.
Why would the Ukrainians do do this?
First of all, why would they fight for
every inch of territory, and why would
they launch a counteroffensive against a
superior enemy a superior enemy?
What's the problem?
Okay, the first is
the president
Zelensky
The guy is a TV actor.
Okay? Which means that he doesn't think
strategy. He just thinks what looks good
on TV.
So, for the first 2 years of the war,
we're watching this on TV, right? And it
looked as though the Ukrainians were
going to win this war.
Right?
It I remember like 2 years ago, people
were saying that the Ukrainians are
going to march to Moscow and overthrow
Putin.
People were saying that.
Okay? And the reason why is that
Zelensky is a master of public image
manipulation, okay? He was distorting
reality for people through television.
The problem with that though is
it's not reality, guys, okay?
Reality The reality on the ground is
very different from TV.
Okay?
So, who else is like Zelensky
in this world?
Trump is exactly like
uh
Zelensky, okay? Do you understand?
Trump is also concerned about what looks
good on TV.
He's like, "I must look strong.
We must look as though we're winning
this war." He doesn't really care about
strategy, okay?
So,
because of this, it's very likely that
he orders a land invasion of Iran
because it would look good on TV.
Okay?
So, the problem with Zelensky is he
cared about what looked good as opposed
to actually what actually worked, okay?
But you also have other problems like
you have extremists
in the Ukrainian military, okay? And
guys,
uh these extremists, they're Nazis.
They're neo-Nazis.
And so, um the traditional understanding
of neo- of Nazis are people who killed
Jews, okay?
But the Russians don't understand Nazis
that way because because remember
Germany and and the Soviet Union fought
a fought this war.
So, the Russians understood Nazis to be
enemies of Russia who want to kill
Russians.
And
there were many neo-Nazis in Ukraine.
They hate Russia. They want to kill as
many Russians as possible.
Okay? And they're they're the ones who
are pushing for as much war as possible.
Okay? So, you have these extremists
in
the Ukrainian military.
Okay? The last reason is
NATO.
So, it's an open secret that NATO is
helping the Ukrainian Ukrainian military
against Russia. You have NATO military
advisers
advising strategy
against Russia.
Okay? So, it's most likely that the
summer offensive last
uh last summer
was a NATO plan and not a Ukrainian
plan. It's possible.
We also know that NATO special forces
are in the country
directing missile strikes against
Russian forces, okay?
Which means what?
If
if this is true
and if
um Ukraine loses the war, meaning that
it doesn't have enough soldiers to
continue to fight this war, what will
NATO do?
Send their own Yeah. Yeah, I mean,
according to what happened to Vietnam
War and uh
the Athenians uh expedition against
Sicily, it is most likely that the most
likely outcome will be that NATO sends
its own troops against Russia.
Okay? So, Macron of France have said
that we are we want to send
French soldiers and the British um
prime minister has said that he's
considering conscription
for British people.
Okay?
Which means that young British
uh citizens will be drafted into the
army to fight Russia.
All right?
So, these are three
historical examples that are very
similar to what could happen in Iran.
Okay? Does that make sense, guys?
All right. Any questions be be before I
continue.
All right. I- Is this clear so far? All
right.
Now, let's use another mode of analysis
called game theory analysis, okay? And
this is what I've been teaching you
uh
this
uh semester. And the idea is that
society, what happens in the real world,
is a game among human beings.
Okay? So, you So, each person
is trying to play this game as to
optimize the outcome for that person.
Okay? So, the question then is
why would the United States send 100,000
troops into Iran?
So, let's look at the
individual motivations of the individual
players, okay? So, you have the United
States.
What does the United States want to do?
What What What What does it want to do?
By By doing what?
And accomplishing what?
It wants to topple the regime in in
Tehran, right?
And you can only do that through a
ground invasion, okay?
So, the United States is trying to
topple Iran.
But then you also have other actors,
okay?
So,
um Iran.
What does Iran want to do?
What what what does Iran want to do?
Or the basically the Revolutionary Guard
Corps, what do they want to do?
To kill me?
They want to kill as many Americans as
possible, okay? Do you understand? They
want to force an American land invasion.
Okay? So, Iran wants to force
a US invasion knowing that
if the US invades, it has to lose the
war, okay? It will lose the war.
Because
the Revolutionary Guard can just send
suicide bombers against the United
States, okay?
Now, let's look at Israel.
Okay? We know that the United States
wants to topple Iran. We know that Iran
wants to force a US invasion to defeat
the the the Americans, to humiliate the
Americans, and and
um
exact revenge for what happened
in the past, okay? What does Israel want
to do? What is is Israel's
ultimate outcome?
Do you guys know?
If you were Israel, what do you want to
happen?
To defeat like all the proxies
Or
Okay. So, you you want you want Iran
defeated, okay?
And then what do you want to happen?
You want Iran defeated, you want the
proxies defeated, and then what what
what do you want to happen?
Do you want the United States to stay in
the Middle East?
What happens if the United States
What happens if the United States and
Iran both lose the war? You know, Iran
is destroyed as a country, the United
States is destroyed as a military
presence in the Middle East. What would
happen?
Israel becomes the top dog in the Middle
East. Do you understand?
Okay?
Israel can now control the entire Middle
East.
So, the optimal outcome for Israel is
Iran and the United States
are both destroyed.
Okay?
Do you understand? How about How about
Sa- Saudi Arabia? What is their optimal
optimal outcome?
Exactly the same as Israel. Exactly. Do
you understand?
Yeah?
Which will leave the Middle East to
Saudi Arabia and Israel, but Israel is a
far superior military than Saudi Arabia.
Okay? Remember Sa- like it's very easy
to blow up Saudi Arabia. They have oil
fields, okay? Not that hot Not that easy
to blow up um Israel. So, Israel becomes
the top dog.
Do you understand game theory?
In other words, all the major
participants want an invasion
of Iraq.
Okay?
But, they want different outcomes.
And
Saudi Arabia and Israel most benefit if
this situation happens, where you have
100,000 US troops in the country and
they can't get out, okay?
Because it becomes sunk cost fallacy.
The United States can only pour in more
soldiers.
Okay? Does that make sense?
All right.
So, is this clear to you guys?
Okay? You can either use historical
analysis
to get to this outcome, but you can also
use game theory to get to this outcome.
Any questions so far?
Okay, great. Okay. So, Celine asked the
most pivotal question, okay?
The United States has nuclear weapons,
which is its ultimate trump card, right?
So, what Trump can say to Tehran is like
500,000 troops in country. You have to
let them go or I will nuke you. Okay?
Do you understand? Trump Trump can say
that. Listen, I'm Trump. I'm Donald
Trump.
I need to look strong. I have 100,000
troops in the country. I can't get them
out of the country. So, he says to
Tehran, you either let them go, okay?
You either get to guarantee them self
safe passage out of country or I will
nuke you.
Right?
So, that's what that that's what will
happen. That is what Donald Trump will
do.
Once the situation arises,
the only way for Donald Trump to save
face is to threaten Tehran and says,
you either let my my guys go or I will
nuke the entire country.
Right?
So,
how does Tehran get out of the
situation?
How do the Iranians protect themselves
against this possibility? Because as
because you're actually right. This is
exactly what will happen if this
situation will arise. Trump will respond
with nuclear weapons or the threat of
nuclear weapons. So, what must the
Iranians do to protect to protect
themselves against this possibility?
Who who can help the the Iranians now?
Russia. Okay, do you understand? So,
before this war happens, Iran and Russia
must come to an agreement where Putin
says from the out from from the onset,
no one is allowed to use nuclear
weapons.
Okay? If Iran new uses uses nuclear
weapons, I will nuke Iran. If the United
States uses uses nuclear weapons, I will
nuke the United States.
If Israel uses uses nuclear weapons, I
will nuke Israel, okay? Putin if Putin
says that, how will the world react?
If Putin says this, you are not allowed
to use nuclear weapons, how will the
world react?
He's a hero, right? He saved humanity.
But because he says this,
the United States is now trapped.
Okay?
You understand?
And so this becomes a black hole for the
United States,
where they can only send in more troops.
They can't get any troops out, they can
only send in more troops.
What's the problem with this?
What's the problem with sending in more
troops?
No, there's a there's actually a huge
problem with with with with this idea of
sending more troops. What what is it?
Okay, you can't like no one wants to go
fight, you understand?
The military cannot recruit soldiers.
All right?
But even if you if you did did have
enough troops,
as Jack says, you can't resupply them.
Why?
Why can't you actually resupply your
army? Why not?
But there's a bigger problem than the
supply lines. What is it?
What do you need to create bullets and
ammunition?
America has no manufacturing capacity
because America moved all its
manufacturing capacity to China.
Okay? Remember this.
So for every one ship that America can
build, China can build 232 ships.
That's what the Pentagon says.
Okay, do you understand?
So if this war were if this war were to
happen,
there's actually no way America can win
this war.
It's just completely trapped inside
Iraq.
And once it becomes trapped, sunk cost
fallacy comes into play, and America
just puts in all its resources into the
country,
but it's a black hole, okay? It cannot
use nuclear weapons because Putin has
said from the onset, you are not allowed
to use nuclear weapons.
All right?
But now the question then is,
why would Putin do that, right? Why
would Putin involve himself in this war?
And that's what we'll discuss next
class.
All right? How Putin sees this war and
how Putin will react in this war.
Okay? But um before we end, are there
any questions ab- about any of this?
Does Does this make sense to you guys?
Is this clear?
Any questions?
Like is it possible
for the United States to invade uh Iran
to Iraq?
Like
if they send their armies to the
Oh, that's a great question, yeah.
Um
so the the problem with Iraq
is
that Iraq is an independent country.
Do you understand? There are 10,000
American soldiers in Iraq.
Um
so you would need to you would need
their their permission.
Even if you had their permission,
there's a problem problem here because
there are lots of
Shia militiamen in Iraq who are loyal to
Iraq, okay? And they would see the
American invasion force
as something as a opportunity to attack
the Americans, okay? Because they're
still angry about the Americans for what
happened in Iraq.
But
even if
they could have a staging area in Iraq,
they still they still have to deal with
mountains, okay? Do you understand?
All right? I mean,
the problem is you have 100,000 troops
in the country. You have to get out of
the country, okay? And it's very hard to
get get them out of the country. If you
go through the mountains, you're going
to get this you're going to get ambushed
in the mountains. If you go through the
air, those drones are going to strike
you down.
Th- That's that's the issue, okay?
All right? Th- Th- Does that make sense?
Okay.
Any more questions?
Okay, great. So, uh on Friday we'll talk
about Putin, okay?